[Music]  you and ozzy will be married 30 years on  july 4th is that right  that's amazing  we have your wedding photo we have a  wedding photo this is one of the  craziest wedding photo  i've ever seen  i love that wedding photo it's fantastic  it's beautiful yeah i like it is it true  that he still  sexts you is that true or do you sext  each other on your phones we sext each  other for valentine's day and i can  prove it because i have it on my phone  he sent me  a picture of him naked and bending over  and he had a one red rose coming out his  bum  [Applause]  i know ozzy i love ozzy but aren't you  worried that he could it's conceivable  he could accidentally send that to the  wrong person but you see i'm so proud of  him and his huge testicles and really  that i just want to share him with the  world  what a strange interview